about for the yankees trying to make it
two in a row over a team that's really
had their number all year long the 29
year old right-hander jameson taiyo
last worked sunday at houston the sunday
before the all-star
break and put the yankees in pretty good
shape to win that game but a notable
bullpen
implosion cost new york his decision
and ty owns out there to make his 18th
start of the year tonight
looks like he's going to get a first
pitch out as a fly ball
for ryan lamarr is handled with ease
[Applause]
then verdugo strikes out two quick outs
for taiyon
so those yankees dealing with 30 year
old southpaw martine perez on the mount
for boston tonight
yeah he features a fastball a cutter a
curveball and a change up
stan has really struggled against off
speed this year
and he's caught looking here for round
number two
hey man here's what i'm talking about it
is just frozen
and that's a little bit of insecurity
but he's just not ready to hit
and that ball is by him and he's still
not gathered
you have to be ready to hit early when
in doubt
be early if you're super down be super
early
but you see right there he's just not
ready to hit and that's not a strong
position
and a called strike three taken by
sanchez back to the cutter
a couple of strikeouts in a one two
three start to the game for martine
perez
scoreless here it's labor torres leading
things off in the second
taurus swings and sends another drive
out to left field verdugo will watch it
fly
maybe this is the start of something
that the yankees have been waiting
all season long for
homer's in back-to-back games for gleber
torres
one-nothing new york
[Applause]
and we talked about the yankee hitters
being late with the wooden leg kick well
this time taurus on time 02 mistake
fastball and he beats him to the spot
on time now watch the leg kick here
a little bit more subtle slow feet
quick hands one out base runner aboard
now for dj lemay here
there goes allen and le mayhew hits the
hole
runners at the corners with one away
and a big opportunity for stanton 048 in
the series with
five strikeouts including his first
played appearance tonight
if you're stan you got to keep it very
basic here the number one goal is get
this run in
you want to think left center right
center do not follow it off do not miss
your pitch
move the ball forward up in the air
chopper to the left side that's going to
get a run and save the no
double play and yes stanton beats it out
two nothing new york good play here
by bogart knowing he can't get to
insuring
the lead guy
yeah i don't think arroyo got stepped on
i think he went into that gene tennis
stretch
and uh look at him man that hurts
that's a legit first baseman stretch the
dude has never played the position
before
and it looks like guys right after the
play like he grabs for his groin muscle
i can understand that
here's honda renfro with the tying runs
on base three balls in his strike to
renfro
odor says he's got it and that retires
the side
two are left stranded still two nothing
yankees
has ground up to short his first time up
all for his last nine
to right field toward the short porch
lamar is backing up on it he leaps and
it's off the roll and lamar is down
vasquez into second
good hitting here by vasquez
good effort
[Applause]
lamar just crumbled as he went to the
ground and it's
it's tough to speculate until we see
what a trainer is looking at exactly
what went wrong for him there could be
any one of a number of things
oh man bear in mind he missed some time
earlier this year
with a hamstring strain
[Applause]
can't tell if lamar's staying in the
game or not it looks like he is
one two to dalby cause popped up
kittens is there odors there and ginny's
makes the catch
vasquez will tag up and get to third it
usually goes that way the guy with the
longest arms has the best
chance and that was big chris kittens so
2a of runner third here's kiki hernandez
into left field allen got a late break
creeps up on it to make the catch
stranding a runner at third yankees have
runners at second and third and no one
out
greg allen full count pitch allen sends
a drive out to center field
duran's setting up to bring it to the
plate or door will tag
up throw comes into third and it's three
nothing new york
second and third two outs here is hunter
renfrew
[Applause]
[Music]
and the yankees keep it quiet gardner a
lead off single
and here is rugey odor
a swing and a big drive from rudin at a
door that one's gonna fly
2-1 homer 5-0
and last time took the butt with him for
a base hit
this time the long ball on the first
pitch breaking ball
and adore watch him wait for it right
here the leg kick on time
and then the blow
[Applause]
and here in the eighth the red sox will
send up verdugo martinez and bogarts
in a seven nothing yankee lead
renfro sends one into shallow right it's
gonna drop
in front of lamar well they tried to
hold
jd but he ran through it and the red sox
are on the board for the first time
tonight
now here's ryan lamarr pitch hit in the
air to right
and deep renfro back on the track and
she is gone
he wants that one back that's his first
as a yankee two-run blast and the
yankees
now have a 9-1 lead red sox down to
their final out is [ __ ] hernandez
and her oldest chapman a couple strikes
away from making it two out of three
to start the second half of the season
against the team the yankees are trying
to chase down in the a.l east and
that will put a bow on it